use one rotation to map quadrilateral
abcd to the other quadrilateral so to
map this one to this one right over here
use a number between 0 and 360 degrees
to describe the angle counterclockwise
is positive so we're going to want to
move it counterclockwise to try to get
it to map there and the only option they
give us because they want us to do it
with one rotation is the rotation tool
and so we have to think about where what
do we want to rotate around what point
and befo if we put it right over here it
looks like this point point a does
correspond to this point right over here
so if we were to rotate this around if
we were to rotate this around not 90 but
it looks like 180 degrees around this
point point a would show up over here it
feels like point
let's see is that right
is that right or well let's actually
just try it out point a would show up
over no no that's not right that doesn't
seem to
let's try it out because if we rotated
180 degrees
oh actually i was right it did it didn't
match up and that's why that's this
that's why this is interesting it tests
tests your visual visualization
skills
so it did actually match up and what i
did is i put that point of rotation
exactly between those points but it
because it looked like 180 degrees
around this point so rotation by 180
degrees about negative 1 negative 1. so
the center of rotation is
negative 1
negative 1 the angle of rotation is 180
degrees
point a
maps to this point right over here so
point a maps to the point 1 negative 1
1
negative 1 and point c
point c which is diagonally opposite
point a
maps to this point right over here which
is 6 negative 6
6
negative six
six negative six
and we got it right